there's a joke that over 99 of modern
VFX relies on this image and there's a
surprising amount of Truth to that this
is procedural noise and through various
mathematical Transformations you can get
really crazy interesting patterns that
are vital to Modern visual effects
it begins with a simple idea generating
random numbers
now VFX doesn't typically require true
Randomness so we won't Force the
computer to roll a die each time we want
a number instead we can use a pseudo
random number generator and this is how
they work you have a function called a
hash function and that function takes a
seed value or seed values internally the
function takes those seed values does a
bunch of math on them and then spits out
some random looking numbers now if you
do this badly well it'll reflect quickly
in the results your random numbers will
look pretty non-random or in other words
you can see patterns pretty easily if
you do it a bit better well the random
numbers really do kind of look random
enough the patterns are difficult to see
or ideally completely invisible to your
eye so we're good to go put a random
number generator is just a start there's
another property of noise that makes it
interesting for VFX and that property is
that it's smooth if I were to plot a
random number generation function
version like the one we made earlier
you'd end up with this which is well
just kind of a mess you want random but
also smooth so instead what if you were
to take the randomly generated value at
some interval say at each integer value
so at each of these points now and only
at each of these points do you generate
a random value and then between those
you'd interpolate the values what you'd
end up with is something more like this
a sequence of pseudo-random numbers but
smooth and continuous the neat thing is
that this extends to higher Dimensions
pretty trivially let's use a grid to
look at what happens in 2D now we'll use
that hash function we defined earlier
the one that takes a 2d Point as a seed
value that is to say it takes two values
and munches them together somehow
spitting back a pseudo-random number
using this hash function at each of
these points on the grid we'd have a
random value let's represent those with
grayscale points and that means that at
any given point in 2D space you find the
four surrounding points of the grid with
those you can perform bilinear
interpolation to get another value and
voila you have your noise value what
we've just created this is what's called
value noise the reason is called value
noise is simple at each point in our
grid we have a random value and those
are interpolated to form noise values
that's all no deeper meaning than that
the only problem is this whole thing
looks pretty blocky there's a pretty
obvious grid pattern here now if you
watch the video on lerp you should feel
comfortable swapping in smooth step or
another variant like smoother step which
gives you immediately better results and
if you didn't watch the video shame on
you go watch it now this is an
improvement but there's another even
better way to get smoother looking noise
though it's called gradient noise and
the idea is similar to Value noise
you've got your grid but instead of
having a grid of points we have a grid
of gradients or basically random
Direction vectors when you sample a
point you find the four closest
gradients and this is where things get
slightly different for each of those
four points you calculate the direction
to the points take the dot product
between the gradient at Each corner and
the direction to that corner and then
you interpolate between those four
values and what you end up with looks
like this which to me looks a lot better
than value noise at the cost of being
more expensive to calculate now we've
mostly touched on value and gradient
noise but before moving on there's
another form of noise that's also pretty
popular and versatile more annoying
noise the idea is super simple you start
with a basic grid kind of like we've
already been doing at every cell in the
grid you start with a point in the
center and then offset it by some amount
using a hash function then to calculate
the noise for any given position figure
out which cell you're in and which cells
are adjacent Loop through them all and
take the Min of the distance between the
position and the cell's offset point and
that ends up giving you something that
looks like this it it's a little bit
organic looking and can be really useful
for any situation where you want a kind
of cellular pattern now you have the
basis for something very cool so watch
this
so here's the plot of an ordinary sine
wave what happens when you take a sine
wave and you add a second one on top
nothing special at first the Peaks and
troughs just get higher and lower but if
we change the second make it higher
frequency but lower amplitude now once
we overlay that it adds a bit of detail
a bit of extra complexity and if I do
that again we'll overlay yet another
sine wave even higher frequency but
lower amplitude and the complexity
increases and if we do this again and
again we end up with these incredibly
complex patterns depending on how we
change the frequency and amplitude of
course
and if I take noise and do the exact
same thing that is overlay multiple
noises at different frequencies and
amplitudes you start to see some really
cool details emerging from this
seemingly random suit this is called
fractional Brownian motion or fbm and it
might not be apparent just how powerful
a tool this noise is it can be useful
for anything you can do things like
adding a tiny bit of detail to a
material to displacing and contouring
the surface itself
modulating the intensity of a light for
a flickering effect or adding a super
easy to do dramatic camera shake with a
single line of code
let's do some more in-depth examples the
classic example is terrain if we look at
the ground at every 2D point we can
sample fractional Brownian motion for
the height to bring it to life giving
you pretty much infinite procedural 3D
worlds and the noise itself can be run
through shaping functions to give it
more personality if I were to say run
ABS on the first layer of noise and then
add a bunch of much more high frequency
noise I get a more desert-like scene
where I can increase the contribution of
the other layers of noise and scale the
whole thing a bit giving me Rocky
mountainous terrain and I can even
flatten out the lower lying areas by
applying a Min value and then coloring
that quickly to give us water I mean at
this point it's basically open-ended you
can do whatever you want by shaping the
functions of it panning out a bit let's
add some random stars because why not
and these are generated on the grid
using hash functions and if you look
closely the big ones twinkle and that's
achieved by Sam noise over time and we
can bring in a planet now by sampling
the fbm using 3D coordinates you get
this noisy looking surface if I
interpret the grayscale values a bit
black being lower and white being higher
some greens and blues for oceans and
land some deserts some ice caps and
we've got ourselves a decent little
world for a couple minutes of work and
this has infinite possibilities
obviously we can add time as a fourth
dimension to the noise
and as I scroll the noise through time
the continents move and shift
effortlessly interpreting the noise in
different ways gives different effects
by blending between successive rotating
bands of noise then using a trick that
is sampling the noise again using the
noise as an offset otherwise known as
domain warping we can build other kinds
of planets it's limited by your
imagination or maybe planets aren't your
bag so we can do something cool let's
start with the base color and we'll use
more annoy noise to build distinct
little cells we'll sample the fbm using
the direction from the cell center to
streak a bit and then kind of just shade
the top darker than the bottom to fake
some lighting we'll draw a circle at the
center of each cell color it white and
then add another circle inside with a
random color and some streaks it might
be getting obvious where I'm going with
this now we can use smooth step to
darken the cell around the eye and also
darken generally the top right portion
making this look deeper a classic
marbling pattern with some red and blue
can create some convincing veins and
some lighting using the circles normal
and a fake highlight using smooth step
gives you some shading finally we do a
step over time to mask the eye from top
to bottom and we've got ourselves a
creepy little effect here feels a bit
Halloweeny
like always I'll get the code up on
GitHub at some point in the meantime you
should check out my Shader course for a
much longer step-by-step walkthrough of
these Concepts along with others
and if you have ideas and suggestions
for future videos make sure to comment
and respond also make sure to subscribe
cheers